world leaders are reacting to the us-led
air strikes on Syria over the weekend
Russia is warning against any more
action and there are increasing tensions
over a group of weapons inspectors
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Greg Powell khat has the latest tonight
the clash between the US and Russia over
the crisis in Syria continued in the
region today investigators from the
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons still not getting to
the scene of the alleged gas attack in
the southern Syrian town of Duma the US
and others saying OPCW staffers are
being blocked by Syrian and Russian
officials Russia claiming problems with
the inspectors movements are fallout
from the recent us-led missile attack on
Syria that in response to the alleged
gassing they claimed more security
clearances needed the UN denies it
Russia also slammed in an audio
interview new threatened US sanctions
this can't be based or have anything to
do with the situation in Syria or any
other country in the world this is
nothing but international economic asset
grabbing Russian President Putin had
said any more missile attacks would lead
to chaos and international relations he
said that in a phone conversation with
Iranian president Hassan rouhani the two
countries the main supporters of the
Syrian regime of Bashar al-assad give
Domino visuals it is considered an
improper wrong act of war mongering in
the UK Parliament there were more
clashes
British jet fighters played a role in
the missile attacks on Syrian chemical
weapons facilities with it strikes which
the Labor Party opposition said needed
Parliament's approval there is no more
serious issue than the life and death
matters of military action command
decisions taken and defended by UK prime
minister Theresa May so we have not done
this because President Trump asked us to
do so we have done it because we
believed it was the right thing to do
France - sent its jets and missiles as a
part of the strikes French president
Emmanuel macron also claimed over the
weekend he was an independent voice even
convincing President Trump to keep
troops in Syria for a longer time I
assure you we convinced him to stay in
the long term acclaim the French
president's office spent the day walking
back again basically the White House
asserting that President Trump makes his
own policy on Syria also today NATO and
the European Union backing the strikes a
donor's conference is planned in
Brussels for next week officials here
are hoping that this military response
can somehow nudge diplomacy forward in
the troubled region but Greg packet in
London Greg thank you